Are you excited to be nominated for Sportswoman of the Year?
Yeah, actually I had no chance to meet other sportswoman athletes...
...but it's the first time to meet all the wonderful champions and athletes.
So, I'm so excited and I hope I can have a lot of opportunity to meet them again.
Do you feel comfortable now that you're in Los Angeles?
Does it feel like home?
It's been a month training in Los Angeles and with my new coach...
...and new skaters and at the new rink.
So, I'm very excited to be in a new place and training center.
So yeah, I'm having fun, a lot of fun.
What do you like the best about Peter Oppegard?
Why do you like him?
Well, it's been only a few days to work with him...
...but he's very calm and collected so I really love working with him.
And I hope I can really ready for the next competition very well.
Who do you admire in skating?
Specially, Michelle. She has been my role model since I was young.
And now, I have a lot of opportunity to meet Michelle and skate with her.
So, I had a lot of fun last week with her in the show.
So, I love being with her and I'm so honored to be performing with her.
What advice would you give to little girls who wanna be just like you?
Because it's a lot of hard work and a lot of sacrifices.
Yeah, I've been watching Michelle and other, a lot of skaters' performances.
And I was inspired by other wonderful champions.
So, I hope many young skaters get inspired by me, as I was inspired by Michelle.